Harvard horror games Oh Danny can't
handle it too much for that guy says
what are you doing are you [ __ ] with
me
are you done [ __ ] with me Danny we're
gonna play this oh yo
so you're the new cameraman huh that's
me you're lucky
hey names Briscoe nice to meet you
is that a pip a shirt that's a Pepito
she's like a TV star reporter after all
oh I've seen her you're pretty lucky to
be teamed up with Pamela right off the
bat this guy wants Pamela is so oh no
it's so hard to control the camera like
I must be drunk or something you hear
that oh there was no sound there was no
sound what are you talking about does it
say IKEA over there I care okay try
ramming into me right now not too hard
though you hear not too hard though here
I come
Briscoe Brasco all right not too hard
you're ready I'm just charging up a
little bit not too hard though I'm just
getting wrapped up not too hard though
just getting wrapped up I got that [ __ ]
on camera Moy that's definitely arrived
ready go back to but I am right here
Briscoe what are you so you're the new
guy huh oh yes Pam Pamela Martel I don't
know you could space to meet you
pleasure is all mine somebody right in
front of you needs help
or if there's some kind of emergency and
I push Pamela I think you should stop
shooting and help them
oh of course
that's just my own personal opinion but
I've seen lots of Kara men that don't
stop and help but I suppose being able
to film a brutal scene calmly as part of
your job to press the button to Warner
Warner about me hey man boy yeah boy I
give you a hand job best cutscene best
game why have I never played this before
holy [ __ ] what that [ __ ] what
[Music]
oh don't worry I'm getting all of this
don't worry about I'm getting all of it
what's that what's that you set your
stomach that was your stomach right okay
great
glad we agree on things dude I'm getting
great shut like spinnerets here it's
gonna look like it would going crazy but
in reality I'm just walking around you
what a [ __ ] more I'm [ __ ] out of
here [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] my right oh
boy oh boy it's it's lagging it's
lagging all right Briscoe that's now
he's just getting [ __ ] annoying oh my
god hey hey you gotta know
[Music]
what the [ __ ] you were into some weird
fetish [ __ ] say it I said it all right
Briscoe what are you doing I know we
gotta set her free Briscoe fresco what
the [ __ ] Briscoe what is happening what
is happening Oh what was that what we're
saying what the [ __ ] was insinuating
that game there I don't know but I think
I could get into this kind of stuff
fresco what's happening what is this
part of the game
if I keep clicking on her Briscoe good
gets full on her this is slightly rapey
and weird okay I don't [ __ ] out hmm
oh my god oh no can i push her over
there Lynch
jerk I'm so sorry
yes damn I swear I try to warn you guys
hey Briscoe don't get all touchy now
thank you very much for helping me
[ __ ] you Briscoe oh [ __ ] your risk oh
[Laughter]
shut up
Briscoe you [ __ ] [ __ ] Briscoe get
yourself together we need to destroy
that thing oh my god what the hell she
got rekt what the [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
just standing area get out of the way
get out of the way every time oh she has
a foot you had a [ __ ] gun all this
time he's Syrian you're just oh my god
that's it shoot there shoot there yes
let that [ __ ] on fire oh nevermind
nevermind oh no I did it [ __ ] you dude
he's so weird
it's so weird Briscoe I'm gonna have to
end this episode here this is a magical
magical game I'm so glad I played this
maybe I'll do more let me know if you
want more leave a like if you do I would
love to and I hope you enjoyed watching
as always stay awesome race